What's Wrong Michael I got gum in my  hair you do this just stinks  don't touch it please don't touch it you  got a ton of dandruff okay let me be  how'd you get going here I was walking  in and I noticed something shiny under  Stanley's car and I gotten under see  what it was and I messed up my hair all  for a stupid piece of tinfoil but best  case scenario you thought it was a  corner kill me right now we have peanut  butter in the kitchen I don't feel like  peanut butter  give me an Ice Cream Sandwich hope not  for you it's for your hair and it is 9  a.m. no Dwight not the good peanut  butter people are gonna get mad hey hey  hey this is my hair we're talking about  smells good tastes good too Oh Donna  that's disgusting Wow a lot of calories  well just don't leave it on too long  keep massaging please  you